today more people are demanding action
to tackle the global climate crisis than
ever before this is a find across
borders across continents and sometimes
bewildering array of critiques and
responses are hitting the public
consciousness we wanted to take a closer
look at one of the most familiar trees
could remove nearly 25% of carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere we're gonna
have to pick trees everywhere the target
is to plug to thousands of trees trees
suck up and store carbon so why not
learn more of them it seems like a
compellingly simple answer to the
question of how humanity can begin to
repair the planet but what do the
experts think I'm a filmmaker here at
the Economist and I want to find out the
real story behind trees and climate
change the world ambition for
reforestation for planting trees has
never been
great private companies have schemes
like even for house for example they had
a scheme where for every hundred years
they would plant the tree
Wow really yeah because it's just an
easy win for companies to say plant a
tree if you do this will penetrate but
it's not as simple as that
and it's not necessarily having the
benefit good thing this represents how
much carbon can be stored if all
reforestation projects are plantations
and this is if you let all forests
regenerate naturally natural slow growth
forests you can see it's drastically
higher so one of the pertinent kind of
questions for you this big study a few
weeks ago that said that tree planting
has mind-blowing potential to tackle
climate crisis so I think that's the
kind of key starting point for our
research looking at to what extent
that's true to what extent trees and
planting the trees can tackle climate
change when this study from the Crowder
lab was published in July these were the
headlines
Janu study is suggesting that the best
way to fight climate change
is through trees it says this could
reduce carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
quite I mean nature sometimes has the
best remedies right so we're about to
call professor Tom Crowder who said the
tree planting has mind-blowing potential
to tackle climate crisis so I want to
speak to him find out how and see
whether it doesn't sound too good to be
true yeah time Tom Crowther I'm a system
professor of ecosystem ecology at ETH
Zurich and we about a year ago he has
started the Crowther lab where we sort
of bring together a lot of perspectives
to have a holistic understanding of
where all the carbon on earth is and how
we could manage ecosystems to store more
or less carbon in those areas why it's
new and important so simply put we just
made a very high-resolution model of
where trees could exist on the planet
and by quantifying how much carbon is in
that land we can actually show that
restoring forests can capture far more
more carbon than we ever previously
thought what we found is actually
forests have the potential to capture
200 Giga tons of carbon since the start
of the Industrial Revolution
we've got about 300 Giga tons in the
atmosphere so it would be very slow and
we have a very it would be over 200
years but still we're talking about a
really really powerful carbon drawdown
solution these numbers you know sound
great but how does that translate to I'm
so glad you asked these questions
because the big media explosion was
pretty devastating wasn't really I mean
it was great got loads of people
interested but it also made led to loads
of confusion and we would never ever
propose that tree planting works
everywhere we're just showing the full
potential it's not like 200 Giga tons
are really going to come out the
atmosphere immediately it would be
amazing if we even reach 10% of that
full potential and so we need all of the
possible climate change solutions in in
concert but I do believe trees are more
powerful than any of anything else that
I know of because there's such a
low-tech easy access solution
anyone can get involved in it you feel
good about yourself when you give a
dollar to a tree to plant a tree it's
more important than the simple carbon
sequestered by trees it's the advocacy
that it promotes I don't really will
address climate change until we all feel
positive and engaged in there in the
challenge and I think it's a beautiful
way to open the door to get us engaged
the message that Tom was keen to
communicate from his study was clearly
both broader and more nuanced than some
of the headlines suggested but is he
right to argue that trees are more
powerful than anything else in engaging
people in the climate crisis we've
written on the merits of different
approaches to this challenge across the
globe
so Asher and I sat down with one of our
senior editors Oliver Morton who
specializes in climate science and
policy yeah well I mean the world some
had other plans are the single most
important thing people can do about
climate change is to plant trees that's
not really the single most important
people think thing people can do about
climate change is to find ways to move
humanity humankind of the use of fossil
fuels which is like planting trees isn't
good but you know by and large getting
off fossil fuels is very important but I
think that's true
almost anything anyone says about any
single action it's a good thing but
there's no magic bullet
if int keepings to take into
consideration when people talk about
planting trees is what else is going on
off the land where they want to plant
the trees and the other thing is that
sometimes planting trees you plant the
wrong sorts of trees in some parts of
the world planting trees makes the world
warmer Simon knows that she pointed us
to some studies which it took into Simon
Lewis I have no idea why you're talking
to me anyway Simon has forgotten more
about trees than I will ever know
[Music]
say some unless is an expert in global
change science and you've been took used
to you along with the detail in fact we
playing up on the website some articles
and other research material and fuel to
take a look at that then click on the
info card in the top right hand of this
screen up now we're on the way to come
an interview with Simon
increasing the forest area on earth is
really important but we should remember
that tree planting is not always good
it's all about the how the trees fit
with the local environment that often
means balancing competing interests for
the land where those trees might be
planted and considering the needs of
local communities but it also matters
where in the world those forests might
grow there are three main types of
forests on the planet encircling the
North the vast boreal forest is
disproportionately rich in carbon and
covers large swathes of Russia Canada
Alaska and Scandinavia diverse temperate
forests grow sporadically throughout the
parts of the earth with more moderate
climate and tropical forests grow along
and close to the equator in the tropics
the trees grow very fast because they're
growing fast because there's lots of
resources lots of sunlight water and
also evapotranspiration water to the
atmosphere which is helping cool that
cooling occurs in part because the
clouds formed by this water in the
atmosphere reflect the sunlight in the
colder north it's snow rather than
clouds that offer the most reflection
growing the boreal forest means less
snow and more dark absorbent tree cover
which means there is less of a cooling
effect is more of a warming effect which
partly offset the carbon storage in the
forest and
according to one study in tropical
forests that grew more than 40% the
temperature decreased by just over 1
degree Celsius in temperate forests it
decreased by around half a degree but in
boreal forests the temperature actually
increased one example of restoration
project that going quite well is in
Uganda on the edge of Kigali National
Park just 20 years after the initial
planting and it's moving back towards a
mature forest and a very high carbon
storage forest so it's really possible
to go from almost nothing to really
impressive forest in in just a matter of
decades in the tropics it's great that
everyone loves trees and loves tree
planting what people forget the
emissions are going straight out in the
here-and-now
those trees might absorb those emissions
eventually it may be 20 or 30 maybe 50
years but there's a big time mismatch we
need to reduce fossil fuel emissions
dramatically and fast and then some of
those residual emissions that we can't
mop up and can't reduce then we could
use some tree planting to do that so
there can be a more limited world for
trees in helping to reduce carbon
emissions but even that's dependent on
the type of trees in forests that are
grown which is why Simon has sent us to
check out an interesting
and very English project I'm here in
Sussex south of England at the net
castle estate there's the castle this
estate is a former farm it was a
standard farm about 30 30 or 40 years
ago and the owners in the fields and
naturally occurring
flora and fauna to flourish here by
leaving them alone we're here to talk
about taking carbon out of the
atmosphere and how much success it can
have not just here but on a global scale
Wilding is a pans off approach it's
become a sort of environment that is a
nursery for open grown freely
regenerating trees within 20 years we
have doubled our carbon sequestered in
the soil we've got the scrub we've got
the grasses we've got the trees all that
will be contributing to this carbon sink
that's actually the start of another
film which you can watch by clicking the
link opposite in it we look at why this
hands-off approach is effective and some
of the big challenges in terms of
forestation at the other link you can
see the economists latest writing on
climate change thanks for watching and
don't forget to subscribe but you can
get all our latest releases
you
[Music]